Good morning John. I've been spending a
lot of time going through the archives
of the Vlogbrothers channels, as we're
doing our This Day in Vlogbrothers thing.
There's a link in the description to that if you're
curious what I'm talking about. But I've noticed
the vast majority of Question Tuesday
videos, they go to you John, and while
this makes a certain amount of sense
because you make videos on Tuesdays, I
think it's a little bit unfair. So today
is Question Tuesday on a Friday. I
asked people on YouTube and Facebook and
Twitter to ask me hard questions and
here's the ones I got. Are you going to
answer this question first? Joe, that was
pretty easy actually. What is the new
Republican healthcare plan all about?
This—this is a hard one because there
isn't a new Republican healthcare plan.
They just want to keep all the good
parts of Obamacare but make it cost
less by waving their hands around. But
if you want to get a little bit less of
a partisan hot take on this one,
Healthcare Triage has an amazing and
in-depth video on this. Is flying to space
the fastest way for Superman to fly? You
know, I don't know too much about the
physics of how Superman's supposed to work.
So if, like, if air resistance is a
really big deal for Superman, then maybe?
But my feeling is that air resistance probably
shouldn't matter to Superman too much, it's
not like he's gonna get too hot,
he seems pretty impervious. So probably no,
it's gonna take longer, but the further
your radius is, the longer your
circumference is, that's—that's how
circles work. But I am not Superman's
keeper. He can do it however he wants to
do it. How do you properly pronounce "thistle"?
You know, I'm not gonna lie to you, I don't know how to
pronounce anything. Every time I get a
little bit confused I just open up
this app, "How J Say." He's just a man who
happens to have said, like, every word, so...
J: Thistle.
What, I mean, what do you want J to say?
J: Butt. Butt. Butt. Butt. Butt. Anglerfishes. Pooping.
Sorry, J. You're my whole world. Thank
you for doing you that great work.
When people come to VidCon, do they typically rent
a car? I don't know if they do, but they
shouldn't, because parking in Los
Angeles is terrible and so is driving.
Get a cab to your hotel. You can probably
walk to the convention center. If you need
to, you can get an Uber anytime. How do
you eat a pear without getting pear juice all
up on your nose? Annelise, I'm a huge
connoisseur of pears. I love them all.
Sometimes I want to get it all over.
Sometimes I want that. But if I don't, I get
out a nice sharp knife and I just, zoop,
right down and I make a little square of
the core and then I'm like, nibble on the
core, then just into strips and eat
them, and oh, it's so good and mess free.
You have to clean the knife, and also maybe your
plate that you put them on. But it's a
wonderful ritual way to spend
time, the feeling of the knife going just
like through that soft, soft Bartlett,
yeah! I may get too excited about pears. I
just realized that for the first time.
Would Bernie have won? For this question,
let's have a guitar.
♪ Well I don't know and nobody else does ♪
♪ and if you think that you're sure then you're wrong ♪
♪ It's too easy to be certain of things that can't be proven ♪
♪ so when you feel that way, sing this song ♪
How's Dave? Well, if you're talking about the
fish, Dave is less good... He can
barely hold up his own string, but he's
still floatin'. How many cats is too many cats?
Well, according to my cat, two cats would
be too many cats, which is terrible for
me because my actual answer is like
maybe eight? I like cats. And pears. ♪ Cat
pineapple apple pear. ♪ Is the S or the C
silent in "scent"? Oh, that's weird, because
"cent" and "sent" and "scent" are all words.
All right, I looked it up on the Online
Etymology Dictionary, says that the C
in "scent" was added in the 17th
century, because people FELT LIKE IT! So
it's the C,
I think, that's silent. Can this be the last
question? Yes. I have here with me,
additionally, a bunch of the prints that
Claire Emery made for us to celebrate our
10th year anniversary on YouTube. Hello
llama! Yeah! I got Claire to loan me this so
that I could show it off. This is the
actual wood block that is put into the
press, and these actually degenerate as
they are used, and so there's only a
certain amount before they lose their
crispness and you just can't use them
anymore. So when you do woodblocks,
it's definitionally a limited run. I love
them. They smell good.
I didn't know that they would smell good.
But that's the thing. I'm—I just wanted
to show you me holding them, in real life,
so that you can see the paper, and what
it looks like, and how big they are, and
stuff. There's a link in the description
if you're interested in these. Thanks for
all the questions, and John, I'll see you
on Tuesday.